Boy, I'm so excited about this
donor party, man.
The Donald J. Trump State Park.
We gotta go Mike!
Sir, I don't feel good about
this.
There's some sort of
darkness here.
I hate the man in the mirror.
I have a bad
feeling about this!
-Hey, you listen to me!
...cause he knows my secrets.
You don't know where we are!
I know where we are and you just
shuttup!
And he says,
“Find the way to destroy
as many people as possible.”
Look, look!
There's a monster
in these woods.
[incantation]
Okay, what was that?
[scary distorted voice]
You are not special.
I'm the same age as you!
[cackles]
[distorted sounds]
We are all the same.
We are all the same
They're gonna know
everything that we did!
We didn't do anything!
-We did it all!
-Stop it! Stop it, Mike!
Take me!
[screams]
[multiple voices]
We are all the same.